my argument would be I did father
Michael Knowles show over right he rises
Studios a while back and he was sort of
expressed to me that he was sort of
feeling uh conflicted what the person he
was sitting and interacting with and the
fact that he you know has to say was
dancers you typically on pronouns and
the thing that came up was well if you
and I were to go to a business dinner or
any kind ener and you were meeting me in
a restaurant and I was there first and I
was in an orange shirt and you had to
tell you know the host I'm here to meet
my friend Blair and they said okay and
you had to describe me to take me to the
table you wouldn't say the man in the
orange shirt you would say Blair and you
would say her over there so for me it's
about sort of real-world application of
it the thing that I hate the most is
being expected needs conversations to
sort of suspend my reality of how like
social interaction really works outside
of the debate so what do you feel about
that you know I think I think there's
some truth to that meaning that I think
that there is a utility to the use of
pronouns but that's not quite the same
as suggesting that a transgender woman
is a she in the objective sense so if I
were to go to dinner with you and there
would be a waiter there and I were to
direct the waiter to you obviously we
would go based off your physical
appearance but the argument for
transgender people is that if you looked
like me you could still be transgendered
woman right they you wouldn't actually
have to go through surgery wouldn't have
to actually go through hormone
treatments you would have to go through
any of that to be perceived as they were
and therefore if it would actually be
assuming pronouns for me to be sitting
at dinner and you to walk up and say
that dude sitting over there right you'd
actually be assuming my pronoun if I
were a transgender and this is the part
where it gets into this really bizarre
space that makes no sense to me meaning
that obviously in terms of utilitarian
effect you're right if I were to walk
into dinner and try and describe you you
look like a woman therefore to the
person there you know I wouldn't be
trying to explain who you were or your
background because what's the point of
that I want to get from point A to point
B in the quickest possible entry from
the front door to the table in the
quickest possible time but that's not to
suggest the truth of the pronoun that
I'm using to describe to the person let
me give you a different example if there
were a person who are sitting at dinner
and that person we're wearing a blonde
wig but the person weren't actually
blonde right I would say the blonde over
there that doesn't mean the parade
naturally has naturally blonde hair it
means that the person is blonde